orange is the new black star Taylor
Schilling has come out yesterday
Taylor's partner
Emily Ritz a visual artist posted this
photo to Instagram with the caption I
couldn't be more proud to be by your
side happy pride which Taylor reposted
on her own Instagram of course Taylor
has portrayed
a bisexual character in the hit series
orange is the new black and in 2019
Taylor spoke to the UK Sunday Times
magazine and had this to say about
sexuality I've had relationships with
men and have had relationships with
women it's been about the person not
their gender it's a much more radical
political act to not reduce oneself to a
label simply to make other people feel
more comfortable I have had serious
relationships with a lot of different
people I like to live freely there are
infinite ways to be in love we just
don't have the language for it yet
and yesterday Hairspray stark Nikki
Blonsky also took to her TED talk to let
her fans know she's gay
[Music]
Niki's ticked off post saw her singing
and dancing to Diana Ross's hit I'm
coming out
Nicki captioned the tic-tock saying hi
it's Nikki Blonsky from the movie I'm
gay
hashtag pride hashtag I'm coming out
hashtag hairspray I love to see it
Congrats to both Nicki and Taylor and
happy Pride Month everyone don't forget
to show your pride oh hey there if you
want more LGBTQ news and exclusive
interviews click subscribe or watch
these videos